[Music]
moving on our main story tonight
concerns trucks everybody loves them
from kids who like the fact they go hog
hog
to produce ourselves reality shows so it
seems cannot get enough of trucks and
their drivers across america giant
trucks with cargos worth millions vanish
into thin air big rig bounty hunters
there's no better way to learn this job
than actually doing it
through
all new shipping wars a new series
world's toughest trucker all new series
mud mountain haulers new series
ice road truckers begin sunday june 17th
at 10. wow
apparently people like their reality
trucker shows the same way i like my
coffee full of ice and intense enough to
make me [ __ ] myself
but trucks are not just a staple of
reality tv they're a vital part of our
economy carrying 70 of the tonnage that
moves around america and the drivers
involved know just how much this country
relies on them if these trucks would sit
shut down
for
one week this country would be in
three days three days three days
this country would be
then shut the country down
there's nothing you eat
wear
drink
drive
doesn't move on a truck
right it's pretty upsetting to realize
that without trucks after just a week
three days sorry three days three days
every produce department in america will
go from fully stocked market to
all-you-can-eat raccoon buffet so it's
no wonder trucking is a huge industry
with more than three and a half million
people in america working as drivers
from port truckers who bring goods off
ships to rail yards and warehouses to
long-haul truckers who move them across
the country to last mile drivers who
take care of local delivery and yet
you've probably heard recently the whole
industry is facing a massive problem all
right we're going to turn now to a
nationwide shortage of truck drivers
major truck driver shortage straining
the already stretched chain and there
doesn't seem to be an end in sight empty
store shelves signal a supply chain in
crisis
exacerbated by a shortage of truck
drivers
yeah that doesn't sound good does it the
only time i'm actively rooting for a
supply chain crisis is whenever a
container ship gets stuck in the suez
canal i don't care if the entire global
economy collapses i just love to see
that big rectangle stuck
the point is trucking companies have
been quick to claim they're suffering a
shortage of drivers they've been saying
that for a while now but the truth is
their actual problem is less a problem
of driver shortage and more of driver
retention because hundreds of thousands
of people become truck drivers every
year but
hundreds of thousands also quit
job turnover for truckers averages over
a hundred percent and at some companies
it's as high as 300
meaning they're hiring three people for
a single job over the course of a year
and when a field this important has a
level of job satisfaction that low it
sure seems like there is a huge problem
so tonight let's examine the trucking
industry how drivers make a living how
they often don't and how companies
benefit from the whole miserable system
and the first thing to know is it wasn't
always like this in the 1970s truck
driving was a solid middle-class
profession with trucker culture even
becoming trendy through songs like
convoy movies like every which way but
loose and tv shows like bj and the bear
about a trucker and his chimpanzee
friend and you're thinking that show
sounds weird you don't know the half of
it
bj was a happy-go-lucky trucker who
would haul anything for a price you are
the guy aren't you the guy holds
anything anywhere for a buck and a half
a mile no questions asked but this time
his cargo was 11 young women escaping
from a white slavery gang roadblocks
mean nothing to bj mckay and xpow xpown
helicopter pilot from vietnam
claude aikens and penny pfeiser star pj
and the bear next wednesday at 9 8
central and mountain
yes
the true golden age of television right
there this whole medium peaked in 1979
and we will never see the mountain top
again that promo started started with a
driver living with a chimpanzee and it
escalated so fast casey kasem didn't
have time to mention the chimp where did
it come from was the chimp also in
vietnam why is it called bear who cares
there's no time it seems we're shooting
guns from helicopters at other
helicopters now those details are just
going to have to wait every year the
emmy should release a statement saying
all awards go to bj and the bear again
try harder next year tv
but the truth is truck driving was
genuinely a decent job but that began to
change in 1980 when jimmy carter signed
the motor carrier act deregulating the
market in an attempt to lower prices for
consumers that set off a race to the
bottom in cutting wages among trucking
companies and 40 years later the base
compensation for long-haul truck drivers
is estimated to be down 50
in real terms and there are three key
problems with the way the industry is
currently set up that we're going to
look at tonight the first is how they
are paid because most long-haul drivers
are paid by the mile not by the hour
raising obvious questions like well what
about when trucks are waiting to load
unload and reload do they really not get
paid for that and for the most part they
don't this is a huge sticking point for
truck drivers if you ever go on trucker
youtube or tick tock which you
absolutely should
you will see a lot of videos like these
why do we have to sit in a dock for
three hours or three and a half hours up
to this point i've been in the shipper
now
for
19 hours no other not many other jobs
where you can just be on the job and not
get paid sitting over there judging me
but i don't have a reload we can't move
it's not me
it's not me it's this bad
i can't help with the dispatcher's
slowest [ __ ]
well you just call and tell him i ain't
go you ain't i don't give a damn if you
ain't got no thumbs you call and tell
him
yeah it's a major problem the waiting
time that is not the fact that dogs
don't have thumbs and can't use a phone
that is probably a good thing because if
they could do that they would literally
never stop texting you [ __ ] like [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] i just saw a squirrel and miss
you love you [ __ ] just saw the squirrel
again and while this isn't a new problem
long waits at loading docks have
actually jumped significantly in recent
years and if you are paid per mile and
lose half your work day waiting you are
incentivized to try and make up for that
time once you're on the road which does
make sense doesn't it if i only got paid
per joke about 80 and t i try and cram
in as many at t jokes as possible i'd be
dropping them like at t drops calls
because the more johnny burns the more
johnny earns
but this can be a real safety problem
for all of us 5 000 people each year are
killed in crashes involving large trucks
now the government has tried to address
safety concerns by mandating brakes and
limiting the number of hours truckers
can be on the road they even require
electronic monitoring devices like this
one that log when the truck is moving to
ensure compliance but
many drivers find that frustrating in a
different way because it limits their
agency over how and when they can drive
we're not computers we don't have an off
button the thing this does do is it
forces you to get up and go if you're
tired it forces you to get up and go if
you don't feel good and it's not about
running 24 hours a day it's about making
a common sense decision on how you feel
how the road conditions are whether or
not you want to run through rush hour
etc etc etc look there are some jobs you
can absolutely do if you don't feel good
like this one for instance i feel like
[ __ ] all the time look at me but it
doesn't really matter does it because
this desk isn't moving towards you at 80
miles an hour so the consequences of my
poor job performance are not likely to
kill anyone and when these rigid rules
bump up against unpredictable work hours
drivers are put in an impossible
position take this driver whose company
made him take his 10-hour break during
the day when he couldn't sleep and then
found himself driving exhausted at night
and when he called his dispatcher to say
that he felt unsafe to drive just watch
how badly the call went
hey man we got a bit of a problem dude
i'm starting to fall asleep going down
the road here but get a load of this the
k b dispatchers instead of telling him
to just get some rest hot potato ape
from one dispatcher to another each of
them with the same advice get some
coffee and then let's because we don't
have it we don't have a choice on this
coffee walk around the truck do
something i already did that earlier man
let's get out and get some fresh air
10 degrees outside yeah that'll wake you
right up right i'm telling you i'm not
safe to drive at the moment
here's the deal we don't have a choice
on this that's not how we work
wow
i don't need that this morning that is a
hell of a statement get out of here with
that dramatic [ __ ] until at least 1pm
it's like the mug says don't confront me
with the potentially lethal consequences
of my reckless decision-making until
after i've had my coffee
so drivers end up getting squeezed
between regulations and the companies
that they drive for and at no point in
the process are their own feelings or
needs taken into account and that is not
the only way that they get squeezed here
because the second exploitative quirk of
this industry concerns the relationship
between drivers and trucking companies
many carriers classify drivers not as
employees but as independent contractors
and while there are some to whom that
label truly applies those who genuinely
have the freedom to choose between
different loads and haul for whomever
they want the fact is many companies
misclassified drivers as independent who
work exclusively for them and whose
day-to-day lives they fundamentally
control and there are obvious reasons
for companies to do this as this trucker
explains i am not classified as an
employee i am classified as an
independent contractor but i have very
very little control over the success or
failure of my company
despite his so-called independence pryor
works exclusively for shippers which
dulls out his daily routes he's seen his
paychecks dwindle and has none of the
protections he would get as an employee
as long as we're independent contractors
they don't have to cover
benefits they don't have to cover
sick days bereavement leave time
holiday pay
it just saves the the company money yeah
of course this is attractive for
companies they don't even have to give
you time off when a family member dies
so unless your nana's wake is being held
in front of the diesel pump at a wawa
you're probably not going to be able to
attend and it actually exempts them from
even more than what he just said there
because it also allows companies to
avoid paying payroll taxes workers comp
and unemployment insurance as well as
the minimum wage and if that wasn't
enough being an independent contractor
means all the costs and risks of truck
ownership get pushed onto the driver
just watch as this former trucker
explains exactly what was left of her
household earnings once she and her
husband had accounted for all their
costs
we made and fifty thousand dollars right
in a year
that sounds great right that's like good
money
we paid a hundred thousand dollars in
fuel
okay so right there i no i made fifty
thousand dollars but i didn't really
because you know you get an oil change
every month so it's 300 a month you you
still have to do all the maintenance we
had a motor blowout right
13 000
right i know i mean i choke up a little
just thinking about it because it was
and it was 13 000 and we were off work
for two weeks so by the end of the year
with that 150 000 by the end of the year
we made about 20
about 22 000
yeah and look i am no cpa despite the
face glasses and insatiable horniness
for numbers that strongly implies
otherwise but that seems like a pretty
shitty bottom line and while most of the
drivers that you've seen so far tonight
have been in long haul this independent
contractor problem also very much
applies to those at either end of the
shipping process too like port truckers
where one study estimated two-thirds of
them are misclassified and also last
mile drivers those are the people who
drive box trucks or sprinter vans to
deliver stuff directly to your door you
know how you see fedex ground trucks
those aren't actually fedex employees
despite every visual indication to the
country they may wear a fedex uniform
their truck may say fedex on it and they
may exclusively deliver packages for
fedex but they are technically
independent if you look carefully at the
side of their trucks you will see small
fine print indicating who actually owns
it and it's not fedex amazon uses a
similar model with its delivery service
partners and again the appeal for amazon
is obvious using drivers that aren't
direct employees allows them to distance
themselves from liability when things go
wrong which they do particularly given
the ridiculous pace that amazon expects
you've probably heard all of the stories
about drivers having to urinate into
bottles because they didn't have time to
stop that speaks to the relentless
pressure to deliver hundreds of packages
per shift
people are
busting their ass driving way over the
speed limit people are
running through stop signs running
through yellow lights everybody i knew
was buckling their seat belt behind
their backs because the time it took
just to buckle your seat belt and buckle
your seatbelt every time was enough time
to get you behind schedule
yeah that's not good is it i thought
that everyone knew the only place it's
absolutely fine not to have a seat belt
is for some reason a school bus that is
where we collectively agreed to skimp on
them as a society the kids will be fine
we'll put a little stop sign on the
outside they'll be fine
and if you think that non-stop pressure
seems like an accident waiting to happen
it already has investigations by
propublica and buzzfeed found that in a
four-year window drivers delivering
amazon packages to be involved in more
than 60 crashes that led to serious
injuries including 13 deaths or that's
more commonly known at bezos's dozen but
again
amazon is basically off the hook here
because these drivers are not their
employees they're independent
contractors meaning that the contractor
is responsible for anything that goes
wrong not them in fact under amazon's
contracts they're even reportedly
responsible for paying amazon's legal
bills in the event of a lawsuit which
you know what is actually only fair it's
not like jeff bezos can afford to pay
all those lawyers he's spending his
money on things that truly benefit
society like launching himself into
space before disappointing everyone and
coming back home safely
and amazingly
i've got one more exploitative quirk of
this industry to show you and it's
something called lease purchase
agreements this is a system where
drivers who cannot afford their own
truck offer the chance to lease one from
the company they drive for with the
promise that they'll earn enough to
eventually pay it off and own it here is
one company giving you the hard sell own
your future with western express find
your true potential and earning power
with truck ownership western's lease
purchase program is like no other
there's no money down no credit check
and no balloon payments at western
express we deliver independence one
driver at a time okay for what it's
worth i am immediately suspicious of
phrases like own your future and find
your true potential companies with
selling points like that typically leave
you with nothing but debt and a closet
full of leggings designed to turn your
crotch into a magic eye poster
and the fact is
drivers who participate in lease to own
agreements almost never succeed one
truckee company executive even estimated
that of all the drivers entering into
their lease purchase program only around
five to ten percent actually ended up
successfully taking ownership of the
truck so the odds are heavily against
you and as for the whole delivering
independence part that is the real irony
here if you are leasing a truck from the
company you work for you are now
tethered to them you are reliant on them
to give you loads to earn money which
you are then paying back to them to pay
off your lease on top of all the other
expenses they can throw at you this has
been a common problem for both long-haul
and port truckers
it takes drivers until each week they
get paid each week and it could take
them until wednesday or even thursday
before they even begin to make a hundred
dollars and the reason for that is
because the company charges them to use
the company truck they charge them to
maintain the company truck to buy new
tires they even charge these guys to
park the company truck at the company
yard overnight they don't they can't
even take it home oh it gets worse in
one case a company even charged
contractors for using company toilet
paper
all of which can lead a driver to
actually owe their company money at the
end of a work week can you imagine
picking up your paycheck and finding an
envelope full of negative five dollar
bills you'd be absolutely furious and
yes that is john wilkes booth on the
negative five which makes sense
he cancels out a lincoln you know
just like how aaron burr is on the
negative 10 and the negative 100
features the 72-ounce steak ben franklin
choked on while trying to win a t-shirt
learn
your history
so drivers are basically stuck here if
they stay with the company they can end
up scraping to get by but if they leave
they risk losing the truck they've
poured so much into us most lease to own
agreements stipulate if the driver
leaves the company it can take back the
truck leaving the driver with nothing it
is frankly no surprise multiple trucking
companies have settled over accusations
brought by drivers who found their lease
to own agreements predatory in fact
western express the own your future
company is currently awaiting court sign
off of a 15 million dollar class action
settlement right now and i know at least
one person who might be happy to hear
that because just watch this former
western express driver talking about how
she felt how she felt misled after
opening a paycheck that came to after
all the company's deductions just 293
dollars
i'm pissed the [ __ ] off if i had the
strength to pick this truck up and throw
it straight to mars i would don't listen
to those recruiters because i'm telling
you they [ __ ]
lying
least purchase here
is a lie yeah and it is probably a good
thing that people aren't strong enough
to hurl a semi truck to mars because if
they were nasa would probably have to
plan their rover missions around the
constant rain of 35 000 pound debt traps
so what can we do here well first we
should probably recognize that we have
all gotten used to the idea of free next
day shipping but crucially someone
somewhere always pays the price
second the work arrangements that
drivers endure and the fundamental lack
of value placed on their time clearly
needs to be addressed and the good news
is the departments of transportation and
labor are set to examine the type of
predatory truck leasing arrangements
that we just talked about they also plan
to study the issue of driver pay and
unpaid waiting times and hopefully they
won't just study it but actually also
[ __ ] do something about it because
the key way to stop this so-called
shortage of drivers that we've actually
had for years now is to make this a job
that people actually want to stay in and
until we make big changes here the very
least we can do is make our trucking
reality shows a little more reflective
of what life on the road for so many
drivers is actually
like trucks the lifeblood of america
they flow across our highways driven by
people tough enough to do one of the
grittiest jobs on earth there's a lot of
ways you can die out here
all right baby we're gonna get there
from the makers of ice road truckers and
world's toughest truckers comes the
realest reality show yet each week watch
the best drivers go up against the
biggest dodge navigating tough weather
bumpy roads and hardcore budgeting
14 grand for the engine
fuel
oil change don't forget the new tires
right
god
oh yeah
these old road dogs have diesel in their
blood and they're living the american
dream yeah it's kind of like being a
cowboy
i'm independent so i got my freedom i
just got to haul what my company tells
me where they tell me during the hours
that they specify
in a truck that i pay for and do not own
but on the plus side
there's no slowing down for these road
warriors because in the freight industry
every minute counts
except during loading and unloading [ __ ]
dang it
come on
because those hours are not compensated
is this your card
yes this show brings you all the thrills
that's pissed
that's my own piss all the drama is this
a charge for company toilet paper a man
needs to wipe
and all the romance of life on the road
i miss my wife
the action literally never stops
hey dispatch
i'm not safe to drive right now i'm
falling asleep roger that driver why
don't you pull over lie down in the back
curl up and [ __ ] yourself right in the
face because i deal with that baby [ __ ]
over well i'm just worried that someone
could get hurt oh somebody could get
hurt i didn't realize i was talking to a
drama queen hey tony get a load of
[ __ ] hamlet over here
[Applause]
to drive or not to drive that is the
question am i right
yeah whether tis nobody in the mind to
suffer the slings and arrows of
outrageous fortune or to take arms
against the sea of troubles and my
opponent and them that's you that's what
you sound like you guys seem to both
know a lot of hamlet verbatim get back
on the [ __ ] road
hell yeah
get ready for 100 excitement 100
adrenaline and 100
well no i didn't bring a coat
oh [ __ ]
and it's not just truckers this show
brings you everyone from the drivers to
the company owners
owners is a pretty strong term
and we have much more casual
relationship with our trucks no labels
i mean
why why complicate things i'm having fun
you're having fun
this paycheck says i owe you money
is that right booyah
yeah
do you have the cash tune into the show
that brings you as close as you can get
to the trucker life without actually
being one okay so yeah neither one of us
go to the dentist anymore and you bring
your own toilet paper to work yeah i
just ordered a new pack from amazon you
what
[Music]
coming to the history channel for some
reason
you